Usually, satellites are put in a graveyard
orbit and left to die, or shot out into space,
or burned up in the atmosphere...
But not THIS ONE!
This one we're going to SAVE!
Hey everyone Trace here with your weekly space
update from DNews!
We've talked a lot about dead satellites and
space junk, but this isn't a binary state,
there are satellites in the middle which are
more like... abandoned sats... and one of
those might just come back from the dead.
The International Sun-Earth Explorer 3 -- or
ISEE-3 -- was launched in 1978 and placed
in a libration point -- or a Lagrangian point.
Without getting too technical, the five L-points
are places where gravity allows satellites
, rocks and dust to stay in a single spot
as Earth moves.
It's like a synced up orbit.
The ISEE-3 was put at a sun-orbiting L-point
and left to measure plasma ejection, cosmic
wind and magnetic energy.
A few years later, it was renamed International
Cometary Explorer or ICE and tasked to be
the FIRST SATELLITE to meet a comet.
NASA used the gravity of the moon and earth
to slingshot into the tail of a comet, beating
the Russians, Europeans and Japanese.
And just because we've got a bad ass over
here: in 1986, it met up with a Halley's comet.
After its triumphant success, the satellite
kept flying... studying coronal mass ejections
on a 30-year orbit around the sun.
When it passed us again in 1997, NASA was
all like, "nah bro.
We've got newer stuff to worry about."
And the mission was retired.
But now, a crowdfunded campaign to reboot
the ISEE-3 is underway by private citizens!
Their plan was to raise 125,000 dollars to
be able to contact the ISEE-3 and command
it to fire its jets, placing it back in its
original Lagrangian point.
The team has already detected communications
from the satellite, and hope to get help from
the Internet at large to fund and analyze
the data that ISEE-3 is still capable of sending!
Their crowdfunding campaign ended on Wednesday,
and as of the time we shot this video, they've
raised almost 150,000 dollars!
They've got a power amplifier, access to a
radio telescope and they're setting up a transmitter.
NASA has approved their plan to contact and
control a satellite no longer in use, and
they now have until mid-June 'til their window
closes and then the satellite will never have
been contacted in living memory!
It's all very exciting!
Assuming all goes well and they can contact
ISEE, there's no way to know what instruments
are working after three and a half decades
in the harsh environment of space.
NASA knows the transmitters were working,
and it had fuel in the tanks, but that's really
all.
It's been in hibernation mode for a long time
and electronics aren't magical.
These people will have to find technology
capable of contacting the satellite in its
native language -- which if you think about
how much computers and wireless transmission
has changed, is no small feat.
It's going to be a big effort.
Luckily, they've got a retired ISEE NASA engineer
on their team!
That should help.
The citizen scientists believe if it works,
they'll be able to put ISEE back at the original
lagrangian point and resume study of space
weather.
Then in the coming years they plan to orchestrate
a lunar flyby, followed by another comet meeting
in 2018!
This is the first time private citizens will
have legally and actually acquired a NASA
satellite.
Private science with government equipment!
Stellar!
What do you think?
We've got comments for a reason, get down
there and leave some.
And be sure you subscribe for more DNews!
Want to come say hi?
Find us at-DNews on twitter or anywhere else,
or me at-TraceDominguez!
Thanks for watching, y'all are great.